well you've covered so many niches from
Metallica and therapy the West Memphis
Three Tony Robbins whitey bulger at this
stage of your career how do you know
when you want to invest time and money
into a story what is it about a story
that you know okay this is something I
want to commit several years and maybe
even a lifetime yeah to dealing with you
know I've been lucky enough to really
cover a wide range of material and to
make quite a few films somehow they keep
letting me do it
and the strange thing is the you know
sometimes you know instead of me
choosing the subject the subject kind of
chooses me at a period in my life where
I feel like you know there's something I
need to learn you know for Tony Robbins
I was open to that kind of thinking for
the first time in my life and it's a
very positive film because Tony had a
very positive impact on my life and I
wanted to share that with other people
you know some people looked at that film
and we're waiting for the third act shoe
to drop where I ripped him to shreds and
show why what he's doing is a bad thing
but that wasn't my intention with
Metallica there was a whole other set of
reasons in my life why that film came to
me so and when I look back in some ways
a lot a lot of the times the the subject
that I need to learn about at that
moment seems to be my guiding principle
as odd as that sounds but it's not just
a passive thing either obviously I
choose the films that I want to make and
generally I look for opportunities where
by focusing on the plight of a
particular individual it shines a light
on a larger aspect of the human
condition and you know I think film is
an incredible medium for social change I
mean I've had the good fortune the works
much of my work has had a direct impact
on a case or a situation
and so I'm always you know if if I can
you know whether it's my you know I just
finished a couple of recent television
series one for spike about it's called
gone The Forgotten women Ohio where the
mothers of these dead and missing
prostitutes were feeling like nobody
cared about their situation nobody cared
about solving the crimes of these went
against these women because they were
prostitutes and drug abusers and I felt
like look everyone deserves justice
regardless of your lifestyle and so I
looked into that case and was compelled
to kind of try to help and provide some
answers so I always look for an end I
felt I could actually make a difference
you know some stories are presented to
me where I feel like I can't get the
access or whatever but you know it's
it's a it's a strange group of criteria
that make me feel like this is the right
thing you know and then at the most
basic level are these is this a
situation or are these people that I
want to spend two two and a half years
with because that's that's the arc of f
of a film excuse me and even if it's an
ugly story that's you know whether it's
a pleasant story or an ugly story that's
not the deciding factor of do I want to
spend two two-and-a-half years its who
are these people can I make an impact
can I be successful in in in my
filmmaking mission and those are kind of
the factors as to whether or not you
want to spend two and a half years of
your life doing something
you